Hi, everyone.
And welcome to MIT's
2020 Online Commencement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Only when we are aware that
our time is nearing an end
do we actually make the
most of the time left
and live in the moment.
So I urge you all,
Class of 2020,
to live the rest of your lives
with the mindset you likely
had when you were told we had
a week left in our college
careers.
Take risks, go all
in, shoot your shot,
find the things that will make
you feel fulfilled every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
As you strive to hack
the world, please
try to heal the world too.
Please help us respond
to this brutal pandemic
with wisdom, foresight,
compassion, and science.
I want you to
promise me one thing,
promise me that you
will be the last class,
the last class to miss
a commencement because
of a pandemic.
The last class to miss a
commencement because of war.
The last class to
miss a commencement
because of climate change,
unrest, tyranny, extremism,
active shooters,
intolerance, and apathy.
Batman and Superman are not
coming to save the world.
It will be up to you.
But never, never in my life
have I been so confident
that the fate of the
world is in good hands.
Go forth and be the
heroes we need you to be.
So get some rest graduates,
and then get started.
There is a lot of
work in front of us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I ask you all now to
raise your right hand
and turn your brass rat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]MIT